make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this is rob and we are back with
secret wars i know it's been a little
while
um i was feeling a bit under the weather
and kind of burned out last week uh so i
just kind of disappeared
for a little while apologize about that
it's just every once in a while i just
kind of get to a point where i'm just
like
because i want to say that for about two
years we've been doing this virtually
non-stop and sometimes i forget that
because i love what i do so much that
sometimes i forget
that i'm just going just just running
all the time
and like every once in a while even i
just need to stop and take a break so
what i may end up doing here in the next
little while maybe once we finish this
i may end up taking a break for like a
week or two but i'll let you guys know
ahead of time right i won't just
disappear on you guys but
what we're doing here is we're picking
back up with secret wars right this is
this is part
three i think it is and the cool thing
about this is that this opens up with dr
steven strange
and dr doom now what you end up having
here is steven strange basically going
over what's happening across the entire
world of battle world for
victor von doom now here's one thing
that i do want to specify to you guys
because a lot of you guys have asked
about this are we gonna cover any of the
tie-ins for secret wars they're not
really tie-ins those you guys who are
new to comic books the way tie-ins
usually work is you'll have like an
event
right so let's let's take for example
civil war that's probably one of the
most popular crossover events that
marvel's done in recent memory we'll
take the events of civil war you have
the main civil war story which was seven
issues long but we know the main civil
war story focused on captain america
versus iron man the tie-ins were things
like the heroes for hire tie-ins where
iron man had gone to like misty knight
and to shang qi and a few other people
like colleen wing and so on and
basically said use your detective skills
to find captain america because captain
america's gone
underground and i can't find him and
that's what their story focused on and
then there were things like the x-men
tie-ins right where iron man went to the
x-men and tried to recruit them to his
side
and they said no we don't want to have
anything to do with that but usually
tie-ins directly involve the events that
are going on
in the main story with secret wars it's
not really that way secret wars the the
various tie-ins that we saw were just
basically stories
involving that one particular thing if
you if you read civil war and you saw
a black panther tie-in which there was
although it was the wedding of black
panther and storm
but let's say you had a black panther
tie-in and it was focusing on what
t'challa was doing during the events of
civil war but had nothing to do with the
civil war event itself that's basically
every single story that goes on here
aside from the main civil war event
some of them are really cool like old
man logan different things like that
most of them are not
[Laughter]
so i'll leave it to you guys if there
are any in particular that you're
interested in seeing but i just want to
kind of nip that in the bud real quick
but steven strange is basically running
over
everything that's happening within the
realm of battle world right so the green
north as it's called
more or less planet hulk you know he's
kind of like you know they're doing what
they always do which is kind of raging
and so on and so forth but there's not
really a whole lot happening here and
the reality is that dr doom is just kind
of like why do you always do this
stephen like why do you always come in
here every morning day after day week
after week month after month year after
year and
read me what's going on over the course
of battle world which is never really
anything that i need to worry about like
why like why do you do this and the
response is stephen strange is
interesting here
because it gives us some insight into
what happened immediately following the
destruction of all the beyonders and all
that power being readily available out
there right we know that doctor doom has
taken that power
the doctor doom has the power of the
beyonder since the reason why he looks
so amazing but the other thing here
that's kind of given to us is that in
that immediate moment that initially
stephen strange was offered the power of
the beyonders right the steven strange
could have taken the power of the
beyonders but he chose not to he didn't
want that absolute power but
it does bother him he does look back on
that and say like i could have been you
so it seems to be some base level of
jealousy not in the extreme but kind of
like i could have been this guy
but the other part of this is that for
him for steven strange because he didn't
really want that much power
he kind of looks around at what's left
right everything that's there that
battle world is composed of what few
universes they could save
as well as whatever they could save from
like the main marvel universe and just
kind of hodgepodge it all together but
he looks around and says this is all
that's left
there's nothing left in the multiverse
but this there's no cosmic entities
there's no other realities there's no
nothing we're it
it's us and like the one above all up
there somewhere and that's all there is
and so he understands the value of this
he understands the importance of what
little they have left and he basically
does what he does because for him it's
honoring that right it's honoring all
those individuals who died
and the collapse of the multiverse
whether they wanted to or not the
destruction of all things and basically
saying like because
this is what little we have left it's
that important and so i play my part
because of the fact that i like to
acknowledge this is all we really have
left
the other part of this is that towards
the end of their meeting towards the end
of their discussion that you end up
having you know stephen strange getting
an alert basically that tells him of
course that thanos and all them have
escaped the raft right now if you guys
remember
in the last video that we did valeria
richards or at least valeria von doom as
she's known now the daughter of victor
von doom and susan storm had basically
shown up to doctor strange and said hey
look we found this device this this
great big huge ship out there somewhere
and steven strange sent the thor core in
order to quarantine it right all these
different thors the police force of
battle world he sent them over there and
basically said
quarantine this make sure nobody gets in
nobody gets out of course thanos the
black the the black order so like procs
from midnight corvus glaive neymar the
submariner all those guys
basically managed to escape killed one
of the thor's but by the time everybody
else got back there and steven strange
is arriving here thanos and all those
guys are gone right and so steven
strange uses
not really the eye of agamotto the
all-seeing eye instead he uses the
replacement that was given to him by
doctor doom by god king doom and
basically kind of starts analyzing
things now this is the big difference
here is that using this eye he can
basically understand where characters
are supposed to be
in time and space right are they of this
particular universe are they of this
particular time and what he realizes
is that thanos and the guys and inside
this ship are not from this time period
like they're not from this this battle
world universe they're from elsewhere
now steven strange
immediately starts putting pieces
together but when he asks the question
like does anybody know where they went
to did any of you guys see where they
went the response is we don't know the
newest recruit thor had taken off to go
get help while everybody was gone and no
one
no one was there to watch them then i'll
send them you know kind of scampered off
and so the idea is they were strong
enough to kill
one of the most powerful versions of
thor that was out there right this this
older version of thor which means they
must be strong and they must be fast and
so they could be
500 leagues from here right they could
be 100 leagues 400 leagues who really
knows and so steven strain says fine
call it 500 leagues
fan out find them and then bring bring
at least one of them back to me alive
right don't kill them all and that's
kind of the important thing here he says
i get that you guys are pissed i get
that one of your member was killed by
these guys and i know you guys want
blood and that's fine but
before you guys get blood i need
information he's like go find them bring
them back and then we'll kind of we'll
settle up you know once it's all said
and done now once those various thors
take off the newest recruit thor still
stays behind right because for him it's
still his first day
it's this guy's first day on the job
right and like oh you know everything's
just kind of popping off but steven
strange at that point
then calls out to the ship and basically
says i know you're in there
get out here right like we're alone you
can stop hiding it's time for you to
come out and the person he's talking to
inside the ship
is miles morales right like miles
morales keep in mind when we were
covering the incursions he was from the
ultimate universe right he stowed away
on that raft that left the ultimate
universe so like he's basically been
here the entire time now the cool thing
about this is that as soon as he arrives
he starts sputtering to stephen strange
right he's like look i have no idea what
happened man like the last thing i know
i was sneaking onto this ship you know
and stephen strange is trying to ask
questions right like you've been on
board this vessel this entire time who
are the other people who are with you
and miles is like i don't know man like
the last thing i remember there was a
world in the sky and like all hell was
breaking loose and like there was a big
invasion and all that kind of stuff and
stephen strange is like wait a minute a
world are you saying that you remember
everything before battle world and
that's not how it's supposed to be
that's not how any of this is supposed
to be now the cool thing about this is
that from here we pick back up with
doctor doom
one of the best things about dr doom's
character and i feel like nobody can
write him better than jonathan hickman
but one of the best things about doctor
doom's character
is that if you look at him before the
events of civil war he was always trying
to acquire absolute power for one of two
reasons the first reason was to free his
mother's soul from from uh from mephisto
because of the fact that she had sold
her soul for some measure of power and
then once she had been killed
he had her soul for all eternity
ultimately in the book um what is it it
was the doctor strange and doctor doom
book and i
don't remember what it was called they
ended up freeing the soul of victor von
doom's mom she went to heaven and that
was basically the end of that the other
reason why doctor doom acquires absolute
power is because his hunger for power is
insatiable right he's like galactus
except on a much smaller scale and
always trying to attain
absolute power that's always been the
crux of his character and there was
never really a definitive answer on what
he would do if he gained that much
we got an answer a couple times during
the original secret wars event but it
wasn't as though he had like lost his
mind and tried to kill everybody instead
he just saw himself as a ruler of all
things right he was just kind of like
now i've attained this absolute power
what he's done
here and this is what's kind of cool
here what he's done here is he actually
looks and
looks at himself from a very interesting
introspective direction but also
he's struggling with kind of an
existential crisis and the reason why is
because as he's talking to susan storm
susan storm starts saying hey like i
went down to the town square i basically
made myself invisible but i went down to
the town square
i was walking around and people were
singing about the song of the man and
the sun and when the question is like
who will like what are you talking about
we end up learning that at some point in
the early days of battle world's
formation that johnny storm the human
torch had risen up against victor von
doom and when that
happened victor von doom had basically
subjugated johnny storm and he was going
to kill him but he left his fate to
susan storm and susan storm chose that
johnny storm should become the sun and
the result is that once he was basically
killed his body was put into the sky
that basically at least
i believe he was killed but his body was
put into the sky and it orbits battle
world and he's literally the sun
and it's one of these things because
susan storm says i think you're failing
to understand the bigger picture here
and when victor von doom asks what are
you talking about her response is people
are giving praise to the sun and it's no
small thing to be worshipped
and what she basically says is the sun
is a thing that's up there that people
can see
that people can communicate with they
give praise to it because it's a
tangible thing that's in there day after
day week after week month after month
but you
are shut up here in your citadel you
never really show people who you
are or what you're about they have a
better understanding of what the sun is
than they do you
and what you need to do victor is you
need to go down into the kingdom and let
your people see you as you truly are and
the response of victor is
no but it's not done out of arrogance if
anything it's actually done out of fear
is that that's really kind of the
biggest thing that's hit here the funny
thing about this is that victor von doom
says how many gods receive
praise when they were seen gods receive
the most amount of praise when they're
not seen because people cannot
tangibly see the things that the gods do
basically some things happen and then
they
chalk it up to god and the best you ever
really get is somebody somewhere
witnessing an event that takes place and
then writing it down somewhere and then
it just gets passed on right the nature
of the bible whether or not you choose
to believe it is up to you and there's
some people who look at that and say
okay well there was jesus but jesus was
probably a schizophrenic right he heard
voices believed he was the son of god
there are other people who look at that
and say no he legitimately was the son
of god and he really did the things the
bible said he did and then came back to
life after three days right came back to
life on easter i think is when it is
when it is but you know nonetheless
in the modern day all these different
kind of events that are written about in
the bible if they cannot be
scientifically explained
are just chalked up to faith and the
whole idea of victor von doom is maybe i
should have just
been a prime mover right created all of
this and then left and then people would
have truly praised me as a god
because he's here and because he's
tangible despite all the power that he
possesses he still thinks like a mortal
which means he's afraid of being killed
he's afraid of all this coming crashing
down but
there's a little more to it right it's
not just that fear there's actually a
lot more that goes into it which will
cover it a little bit later but what we
end up doing here is we switch to the
hidden isle of agamoto and what this
basically appears to be is an island
that not even victor von doom can see
right it's a section of battle world
that only steven strange knows about and
only steven strange can
access along with whoever it is that he
chooses to bring here and when he ends
up bringing miles and thor here we end
up learning
that he found the other vessel at some
point in time but he never really gave
any thought to it the reason why this
matters and the reason why this is
important is because remember
stephen strange was not on earth when
the vessel was created right he was not
on earth when reed richards and the
illuminati and the rest of those guys
were basically creating this life raft
as a means to like escape the collapse
of the incursions remember he was out in
space
with like the black priests and then
eventually with doctor doom and facing
off against the beyonders he had no idea
any of this happened and so for a vessel
to just kind of arbitrarily wash up on
the shores of battle world for him was
just like okay this is just
part of whatever world happened to exist
out there and he never really gave it
any thought he's like you know
like we put this place together with a
hodgepodge of different worlds and maybe
this was just part of one of those
worlds you know maybe that's just all it
was and
that was it you know with the the more
recent ship this identical to this one
having been opened up and then people
coming out of it then suddenly he's like
okay there's more going on here than i
initially thought and that's when he
basically ends up having this battle
world version of thor
open the raft and when that happens you
get jane foster thor you get carol
danvers peter parker spider-man and you
get star-lord peter quill
survivors here and they initially don't
know this is really stephen strange
right they're like we don't really know
if it's
you but of course you know he kind of
challenges them a little bit and then
he's met by the arrival of cyclops who's
in the full possession of the phoenix
force keep in mind one of the things to
remember is that yes there was a phoenix
egg and yes during the events of
avengers versus x-men you did have the
phoenix 5 but those five pieces of the
phoenix force had all coalesced down
into the phoenix egg and so
cyclops is in possession of the full
totality of the phoenix's powers he is
an omniversal force of power that's what
he is now this gave us a
massive hint as to what was going to
happen the reason being that if the
phoenix force really is the sum total of
all life that has ever currently does
and will ever exist then it means that
cyclops is the walking embodiment of
everything that ever existed across the
entirety of the multiverse before the
events of battle world and everything
that will come after which basically
solidified that we were going to get you
know everything coming after that now it
also kind of made sense from a public
publishing initiative it wasn't as
though marvel was like okay guys we
finished battle world
time to close the doors everybody you're
fired it's been real guys
that wasn't gonna happen right like but
it's important to understand cyclops has
a vast amount of power right now but the
fact remains that with black panther of
course showing up black panther
basically solidifies yes we're from the
main marvel universe when he says
memento mori and steven strange responds
illuminatus so basically like it's the
calling card but then he basically
starts telling them what's seeming what
seems to be going on here right
everything that's kind of happening here
that in reality for the people for for
these guys inside this ship
it's been an hour that for this hour
reed richards has basically been
grieving over the loss of susan
and the loss of johnny and all those
guys who basically just ended up
disintegrating
basically perishing or at least seem to
have perished in the collapse of the
multiverse
but what he says here is that you guys
have been gone for a very long time it's
been an
hour for you eight years have passed
here on this battle
the reason why this works and at least
the reason why this seems to work
although it does seem kind of kind of
throwaway and what kind of led to our
own imagination here
is that when it comes to what had
happened out there that they've
basically just been
in stasis that we can largely assume
that with the collapse of the multiverse
also say also came the death of time and
space
right that like time doesn't pass and
there was there was no real space out
there right there was just this giant
empty white void and grabbing what was
left and throwing it down there then it
was basically it now on battle world
time seemed to pass but for them just
kind of being out there they were left
in stasis and the idea is that when
stephen strange keeps chiming in and
basically saying that like god is the
person who saved us god's a person that
created all of this all that kind of
good stuff then suddenly you have the
question asked by
reid who is god how is it possible that
like nobody here knows right because
that's the thing that stephen strange
says nobody on battle world knows how
things used to be
despite coming from universes that used
to exist none of them know how things
were
eight years before all of this and this
is probably one of the biggest things
because when peter asked the question
how is that possible the response to
stephen is well how much of eight years
ago do you recall you might recall a
moment from eight years ago but you
don't recall the world as you saw it
when you were walking around
downtown you know and just like getting
ready to go into a store you don't
recall every facet of eight years ago
and it's very easy to manipulate that
it's very easy to say well i mean you
remember this moment from eight years
ago but you don't remember everything
else from eight years ago and here's
everything else that was going on eight
years ago that combined with the fact
that education which is to say like what
people are taught in battle world is
tightly controlled by doctor doom
basically means that people are only
taught what they're allowed to be taught
and so
over the last eight years or so the
thought process and the memories of all
the people on battle world have
basically been kind of converged and
moved and coalesced they've all
essentially been convinced that battle
world has always been this way and
nothing was ever
anything before this and so again when
the question's asked by reid like who is
it right who who is this god that saved
all of us the response to stephen is
it's doom that victor von doom saved us
all and they're all in just like total
shock like what and what in the hell
and that's when t'challa starts to pick
up on things and he says how long ago
did you find our raft and steven says
like i found it three years ago and i
knew
that there was something inside a great
consequence but i had to weigh that
against
other things reid gets pissed he's like
wait a minute so you're telling me
that victor von duke a guy who spent his
entire life trying to acquire absolute
power so he can effectively
subjugate all of creation has achieved
that goal and you had to weigh that
against other considerations like
what could have possibly been the other
consideration that you had to weigh this
against
and the response of stephen is it's easy
to explain he's very good at playing god
at that point we switch back over to
thanos right we jump directly to thanos
after having killed some food and
basically made a meal and everybody's
finished feasting and one of the things
that maximus picks up on maximus the mad
picks up on is
the sun orbits the earth and not the
other way around right whatever this
land happens to be the sun orbits it and
it's just these small little things that
seem strange these small little things
just seem so
weird which obviously they've picked up
on the fact that this is not the earth
they came from that whatever it is that
they're
at it's starkly different from where
they used to be and so in that time
you end up having you know the ultimate
universe version of reed richards who
says
we should not have killed that older
thor right we should not have killed
that guy we should have asked him things
we should have taken him prisoner and
asked him things he could have given us
answers about what this place is
about how all this stuff works and
everybody's really kind of like yeah man
like we really should right like they're
all looking down to the fire the whole
time thanos is looking up right he's
just kind of looking up into the stars
and and so on and so forth and he's like
there's no need for mercy right there's
no need to regret what was lost
and the question of black swan is like
really because like i think that if we
had kind of asked him
what was going on here that he could
have given us answers to our questions
even if only under like pain of death
and the response of thanos is no the
answers will find us
i absolutely know that it will and when
he's asked how do you know thanos says
because
i'm looking up the entirety of the thor
core
all these different versions of thor are
all descending down upon
thanos they are all coming to find them
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explained make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
do
[Music]
you